we have developed a very special bond so
people are gonna be very impressed
people are gonna be very happy and we're
going to take care of a very big and
very dangerous problem for the world it
worked out for both of us far better
than anybody could have expected
president from talking positively as he
and Kim jong-un signed a joint statement
at the end of their Singapore summit
let's bring in our panel back in DC
Molly Hemingway of the Federalist Mara
liason from National Public Radio and
Byron York of the Washington Examiner
Byron your thoughts about the summit and
that agreement that we just showed that
President Trump and Kim jong-un sign
well I think the most reasonable
assessment you can make of it is that we
don't know if it's going to work out or
not in the joint agreement that the two
leaders released Kim pledged to
committed to denuclearization but
previous North Korean leaders have
pledged to the same thing and not done
it so you can't say there are also other
issues talk about the u.s. military
exercises whether that's really a big
concession or not since Tom cotton
earlier on this program said the next
big military exercises next spring so
that if Kim is operating in bad faith
we'll certainly know that by then my
sense was it's a net plus because of the
relationship between the two leaders and
what has been said but you just don't
know what's going to happen I want to
pick up Mara on Byron's first point
because Kim in the joint statement
committed to complete denuclearization
that's the quote but he did the same in
his first meeting with South Korean
president moon back in April do you see
anything more here do you see any more
details any more meat on the bone not
yet but that's why Secretary of State
Pompeo is now going to pick up the ball
and see if they can do that flesh it out
denuclearization means one thing to the
US and it means some
different to North Korea I think they
see it more as a freeze but the one
thing you can say is this is so much
better where we are now than when they
were threatening to blow each other up
and as long as they're talking they're
not going to war and even if this ends
up with only a freeze and not complete
utter denuclearization that's still
better than what we've got now I think
the only danger for the president is
that it's going to be hard to keep up
the sanctions regime because that really
depends on China and as long as kim
jeong-hoon is talking to the US it seems
like china is already beginning to back
away from enforcing sanctions
yeah let's pick up on that point Molly
because the president says he's going to
keep the sanctions up he's not going to
call it maximum pressure anymore but he
thinks he says that's what it's going to
be but he also complained that China is
easing up on patrolling and enforcing
its Porter South Korea is is eager to
begin trade with North Korea and I guess
the question I have is with with Sherman
Kim now at the end of the summit a much
more respectable normalized figure in
the world diplomatic channels is it
going to be harder to keep up the
international sanctions well it's
important to remember that the success
that we've had thus far has been due in
large part to this very strict sanctions
regime and so to abandon that or to ease
up on that without something solid in
return might not produce results that
that we would like to see and what I
think that President Trump and Mike
Pompeo have been talking about is the
importance of North Korea choosing a new
way of being seeing that it's in their
interest to have a different course of
action than the one that they have taken
sanctions are key to helping them see
that it is in their best interest to
have a new approach a less bellicose
approach one where there is more freedom
in terms of free enterprise and
individual liberty for their people and
so I would hope that everyone would
understand the importance in keeping
this together we might need to ramp up
our pressure on China and other
countries to make sure that that that
does take place
malee your general thoughts about the
summit there are some critics who are
saying that the president gave too much
it considering what a god do you think
that's fair I I mean it's kind of funny
we've had so many pundits be so wrong
for so long a year ago we were told that
we were on the brink of nuclear war
because of the approach that President
Trump had taken that we would never get
to a summit that he would never walk
away from a summit that we couldn't hit
a June 12th meeting time and time again
the foreign policy experts have been
wrong about what would happen with
president Trump's very different
approach from the bipartisan consensus
that we have seen leading up to this in
fact we have not like previous meetings
with that we had we actually had to give
cash money to get them to the table we
didn't have to do that this time we have
a lot of leverage they also are a
nuclear power which it puts them in a
different position than they have been
in previous in previous scenarios this
is a really good first step as Byron and
Mara pointed out the word commit is in
this agreement I think eight times the
devil will be in the details this is the
first step it's a very promising step
there is reason to be happy but we have
a long way to go to see that this
actually accomplishes the peace that we
all hope for Byron I want to go back to
this issue of denuclearization because
the way it is stated in the joint
agreement is the complete
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
now for the u.s. that means the the
North Koreans got rid of their nukes for
the for the North Koreans it means that
all nuclear weapons are gone now we
don't have nukes in South Korea but we
do have bombers with nukes we do have
ships with nukes we do have submarines
with nukes given the fact that this
calls for the complete denuclearization
of the peninsula and the president
agreed to end the joint military
exercises with South Korea any concern
on your part that there's a danger that
US will fold its nuclear umbrella which
is a nuclear guarantee to protect South
Korea and Japan no I don't think that's
contemplated and I think the president
actually specifically did address that
that that is not in
the united states definition of
denuclearization one additional thing
talking about the the sanctions and
whether they had what effect they had on
this yes I think tough sanctions on top
of previous sanctions did have a big
effect but also the threat of war had a
big effect I don't know how many
analysts we have heard over the years
saying that war is not an option on the
Korean Peninsula or war is unthinkable
on the Korean Peninsula what the truck
military team was thinking about it they
were working through scenarios and I
think the North Korea's knowledge that
this seemingly unpredictable man who had
become the president was actually
working through plans for war war in
Korea I think that really caught their
attention